in Guanajuato Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with mummies
[Music]
mi nombre es palomero vez la que yo yo
le directeur Adel museo de las mamiya's
de guanajuato el museo de las Diez de
guanajuato es un resent o sagrado KX e
una collection name o Mia's naturalist
with 117 bodies in total the museum has
the largest collection of natural
mummies in the world the mummies are the
well-preserved remains of people who
died during a cholera outbreak in Mexico
in the 1800s the museum is a haunting
and eerie experience for visitors an
opportunity to stare death in the face
Biron abuse carries experiencia intima
sa encuentro Mistico con la muerte que
propecia la refreshen enter no a la
intención su propia vida y Ascencio de
la misma es importante que las personas
nor a tengan miedo la muerte yell
contrary o lo veo cómo phenomenon
natural como una transición inevitable
de su axis 10 sia porque finalmente 7
encontrar con ella
[Music]
it's very different from every other
collection in the world and if you're a
collector at heart you can't really stop
my name is chef mm I'm the curator and
owner of the Icelandic phallological
Museum
my father was giving a ride bull penis
epistle back in 1974 as a joke and
that's almost part of the idea you know
to start collecting these things all the
lights are made from scrotum skins right
now we have 285 different specimens it's
still growing the collection we get
maybe three to five every year the most
fascinating things is the diversity
there are huge differences in size
shapes a color etc here is the the
biggest specimens we have it's a sperm
whale it's about 70 kilos maybe 150
pounds and here is one of my favorites
the world was one the hardest to get was
the human one no question about that it
was 95 when he died so this person is a
bit shrunken
it's what age does to people everything
shrinks but we're hopeful we'll get a
better example show
[Music]
people say you know there are just happy
because they realize that there's
nothing lewd here there's no pornography
it's just you know education and fun
[Music]
you
it can be beetles that come off a cactus
it can be the dried urine of a cow
little insects that grow on an oak tree
a chunk of lead that's soaked in vinegar
it's truly amazing
we're in Harvard University outside the
thoughts pigment collection pigment is a
very small particle of colored material
that is mixed in with a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its color the
force pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2,500 pigments we have a lot
of very unusual and very rare colors so
this is I think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
dragon's blood it doesn't come from
dragons it comes from rattan palms and
it gives a very bright red pigment the
unusual aspect of mummy has to do with
its source rather than the color itself
and that comes from Egyptian mummies and
it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages I think the
rarest color that we have is actually a
an entire ball of Indian yellow and this
is a pigment that is made from the dried
urine of cows that are fed only on mango
leaves
if you're looking at a work of art and
you want to understand what is original
and what's a restoration you will take a
tiny sample of pigment and analyze it a
lot of the pigments are actually toxic
so you don't want to handle the pigments
and then go out to lunch
there's a green called emerald green
that has an arsenic Center to it we can
use them for telling if something is
real or not people will say this is by a
certain artist and we can look at the
materials that are used and decide if
those materials were available during
that the artists lifetime if not then we
have to look at who might have painted
that picture I can't pick a personal
favorite there it's like asking to pick
a favorite child
no the other 24-hundred would feel left
out
[Music]
some of the greatest works of art are
just beneath the waves standing in just
25 feet of water off the coast of Cancun
Mexico the Messiah sub Aquatica at the
arte is both a monument to human
creativity and the natural beauty of the
Caribbean reef ecosystem the museum is a
vast collection of underwater galleries
with over 500 sculptures many focused on
themes of human interaction and impact
on the environment the Marine Park where
the museum is located is one of the most
visited stretches of water in the world
with nearly 800,000 visitors each year
immense pressure is placed on the native
reef ecosystem that's why every
sculpture is made from cement suitable
for the growth of coral seaweed and
algae the many holes in the sculptures
make perfect homes for marine wildlife
to colonize and feed off the coral the
hope is that as nature continues to
colonize these statues they will
transform into massive reefs
unrecognizable for what they once were
and it's also attractive to humans it
has become one of the most popular dive
locations in the area hopefully
signaling a more prosperous relationship
between man and nature
[Music]
we have sounds be
the Smithsonian's National Museum of
Natural History has over a hundred and
forty-four million objects like this
narwhal tusk my name is Kirk Johnson I'm
in charge of all of them 99 percent of
the collections are behind-the-scenes
and these are the people that work with
them this is Carla dove from the
division of birds here in the division
of birds we have somewhere around six
hundred and twenty thousand museum
specimens and that represents about
eighty-five percent of the diversity of
birds in the world you look at these
specimens and you realize that this is
where the science is really gonna start
we're using our collections to identify
birds that kalaiy with airplanes and
help us improve aviation safety dr. Bob
Robbins curator of butterflies and moths
I have been professionally employed as
an lepidopterist we worked some
butterflies for about 35 years this is
the essence of my being is to know
everything about butterflies there's a
whole world out there that unless you
look very closely you don't see and it's
an interesting world it's a fascinating
world and it is full of practical value
for human beings strong curator of
mollusks what I love about this
collection is its breadth we estimate
that we may have as many as 20 million
specimens we are preserving a record of
past life on this planet of present life
on this planet and preserving that for
the future I take that responsibility
very seriously and providing access and
caring for the specimens for posterity
dr. Jeff post cured of the National gem
and mineral collection
minerals in this collection go from
something that formed maybe in the last
few tens of years to others that form
more than three billion years ago we
know right now there's more than 5,000
minerals that make up the earth and in
our collection we probably have more
than half of those each one's a little
piece of the puzzle and you try to put
all these things together and hopefully
eventually understand the big picture of
how the earth works employed chocolate
collection manager for entomology we
have just a little over 35 million
specimens in the collection a third of
all insect life on Earth is represented
by at least one specimen our collection
when you look at a collection the size
of ours you're starting to get to a
point where you can ask really big
questions the questions related to
global climate change habitat
destruction and you can only answer
those big questions with you have a lot
of specimens collected over a long
period of time a lot of different
species to understand the earth and
living things of the earth you need to
collect those things and preserve them
and study them and that helps you when
you need food when you have a disease
all that stuff arcs back the fact that
we have samples of the whole planet here
and that's how we understand the planet
[Music]
you
strong Museum in Rochester New York is
also known as the National Museum of
play more than half a million objects
are here
my name is Chris bench I'm vice
president for collections at the Museum
and its chief curator our collections
are divided by category and here are
some of the people who are responsible
for them in our collection we have
around 10,000 board games and it
parallels essentially American history
since the Revolution when you think in
terms of games they all tend to
represent the areas in which they were
created it's a different way of getting
into the mindset of people who lived a
hundred years ago in this collection we
have more than 15,000 dolls and expands
from the 18th century to present day
dolls are special because of the way
that we connect with them we project
ourselves our hobbies or interests or
values towards others when we look at
the history of dolls and how we played
with them it shows that we connect to
people from the past in ways that we
might not have expected we have over 250
arcade machines and over 100 pinball
machines in the collection pinball is
real you can feel the way the game plays
you can feel the way the game moves and
you're dead you're playing it's just in
my nature to keep his machines going
they were made the last five years in a
commercial environment and the fact that
we have games that are 30 40 50 60 years
old is amazing to me
[Music]
like action figures in yo-yos this
collection has more than 70,000 objects
toys always reflect what's going on in
the world around them when it's economic
boom times construction toys are big
when the US is at war we see all sorts
of military and war toys the toy
collection is a wonderful example of how
times have changed and people have
changed over the years changed over the
years can we understand how we've
developed as people and how we've played
over the centuries
[Music]
you